- So the bartender says, I
don't know about you guys
but I ain't puttin' on one of those hats.
He was wearin' one of those hats.
Get it?
- No, no, I don't think we do.
- Aw, come on, you guys are from Texas.
- Well, Tennessee actually.
- Texas, Tennessee, I
got a cousin in Iowa,
it's all the same.
You guys really didn't like that joke?
- No, it was confusing.
We've known quite a few
Jews, none of 'em have wings.
- And even if they did have
wings, that'd be pretty rad
just flyin' around eatin' matzah balls
while still also hating
yourself, I get that.
- Yeah, that sounds like a
sweet [beep] Friday to me.
- Look, we get it, alright, the accents,
the Fox News level of anger
that we emit, the cheap beer.
- Hops give me gas.
- But you think it's because we think
that fancy beer makes you gay.
- You gotta drink liquor
if you wanna lick her.
- That's gross.
- Come on.
- The point is, just like how
not everyone with your accent
wants to beat his wife
with a pepperoni stick.
- Oh yeah, shout out to
your cousin Tony and all.
- Oh, great guy, gets out in a year.
- Not everyone with
our accent is ignorant.
- Yeah, or wants to get rid of the blacks.
- Likes rubbin' buttered
corn on their belly.
- Can we get the bill?
- Aw, come on, guys, I didn't
even get to tell you the one
about how Puerto Ricans can't tap dance.
- It's not just that it's
offensive, you're not funny.
Like even in the world of,
I got a racist joke for ya,
yours are just bad.
- You're like a little
league racist and you suck.
- My uncle's in the Klan
but at least he gets timing.
- Your premises are weird.
- Nobody's buying your
logic, man, not even you.
- The thing about the Asians felt forced.
- Yeah, maybe skip that one
at the rally next weekend, Jon Vito.
- Look buddy, you should probably
just stick to the classics
before you go branching out.
For example, the way they
smell, that's always a big hit.
- Or, women aren't safe around 'em.
- How they're allergic to possums.
- The point is, we really don't appreciate
you assuming that--
- That just because we have these accents
means we hate minorities.
(groaning)
- Oh, [beep].
It happened again.
- Fancy beer makes you gay.
- Get rid of the blacks.
- The thing about Asians.
- The way they smell.
- Women aren't safe around 'em.
- We don't like minorities.
- They only heard the bad parts.
- Yeah, we know, we're going.
And here's all my money, hope
Confederate bills are okay.
- Let's go, Corey.
- We're not all bad people
and we know that Jews don't have wings.
- You stay golden, ponytail.
- I can't believe you had to sit beside.
those racist monsters.
- Yeah, it was horrible.
I was trying to tell them about the blacks
and how their lives matter.
- Honkeys.